in this course you will learn the basics
of reinforcement learning and how to
implement it using gymnasium gymnasium
is a software Library by openai that
provides a collection of pre-built
environments for reinforcement learning
agents in this course Mustafa will show
you how to use gymnasium to test and
improve your reinforcement learning
algorithms
so what will be the objectives of the
course so what we're really doing is
we'll be learning the basics of
reinforcement learning and open air
gymnasium
you will learn how to use the gymnasium
interface to interact with different
environments
we'll explore various gymnastian
environments so the environments could
be like a taxi environment it could be
like a blackjack environment if you have
different Atari games as well and we'll
also understand their characteristics
will build and evaluate reinforcement
learning agents using gymnasium
prerequisites knowledge of Python
programming language so you need to be
familiar with basic Loops what is a
class what are different methods so I'll
explain it to you while as we go along
basic understanding of reinforcement
learning Concepts so whatever the topics
that are required I'll be explaining in
it to you while we are while we start
the course
introduction to reinforcement learning
what is reinforcement learning we will
learn the RL Technologies and also we'll
understand the reinforcement learning
workflow
my next section is Introduction to open
a gymnasium so I'll introduce you to the
open air gymnasium and also we will set
up the gymnasium environment
and I'll also I'll explain you the basic
concepts that are required for using
gymnasium so which could be the
environment agent observation action and
reward
the next section is gymnasium
environments so we'll understand the
types of gymnasium environments
we'll we'll understand the difference
between continuous and discrete actions
and observations
understanding the properties of
different gymnasium environments and
also those are the games Classic
Controller Atari box 2D robotics
these are different types of
environments available and there are
many more available so Blackjack we have
taxi environment we have frozen leg
environment
so now let the next station is the
gymnasium interface we'll be interacting
with environments using the gym
interface
we will understand the gymnasium API and
we'll create some custom environments
now the next section is building
reinforcement learning agents so we'll
be implementing RL agents using
gymnasium we'll understand the algorithm
Q learning will be training and
evaluating RL agents using gymnasium
and we'll be improving RL agents with
policy search and other techniques
basically we will be solving Blackjack
using queue learning this will be the
that section so let me just write it
down
I don't know
which means that will be the tutorial
and these are the advanced topics so
after you get a basic understanding of
these
reinforcement learning gymnasium and
solve some solve a problem then you can
go and explore the other Advanced topics
so the these are the
using open AI baselines for benchmarking
RL algorithms creating and using
wrappers to modify environment Dynamics
combining multiple environments to
create more complex scenarios so we can
have two taxis coming at each other
or you can have multiple players in a
poker environment so basically you can
simulate those environments also we'll
be integrating with other tools such as
tensorflow and pythons
okay so basically that is the course
now let's look at the conclusions so by
the end of this course you will have a
very strong understanding of
reinforcement learning and open air
gymnasium
you will be able to use gymnasium to
build and evaluate RL agents and will
have a very good understanding of the
different gymnasium environments
available
this course is an excellent starting
point for anyone interested in
developing or working with reinforcement
learning system
let's start with the basics of
reinforcement learning it is a type of
machine learning in which an agent
learns to make decisions by interacting
with an environment so basically as you
can see here I have an agent and I I
have an environment so basically let's
take an example of a robot so what will
happen is that the robot when it takes
an action suppose it takes a step
forward
so we will reward either we will reward
the robot for that action or either we
will penalize it for the
action so how will we decide that so
what the basic policy would be that
suppose if the robot takes a step and it
bangs into a wall so we will have to
penalize it and we will deduct some
point for that or if the robot takes a
step and it doesn't Bang into anything
that will be a a good
action so we will have to give it some
points so this is basically that's what
will happen so what is an agent an agent
is an entity that interacts with an
environment in order to learn how to
make decisions that will maximize a
specific goal or objective so basically
in our case when we have a robot we need
it to take something from one place to
another place so basically it has to
reach the particular endpoint
so we will have to train the robot to
reach that goal
so it will take the precision
autonomously as it receives input from
the environment performs actions and
receive Rewards or parenting bets on
this actions
the environment on the other hand is the
external system or context in which the
agent operates so basically in our case
everything that is can is nearby to the
robot is the environment so basically it
could be a warehouse so the full
Warehouse will be the environment and it
will be interacting with the robot will
be interacting with the environment so
it can be a simulation a physical system
or any other system that the engine
interacts with
the environment provides feedback to the
agent in the form of Rewards or
punishments means the agent uses to
learn how to make better decisions
the agent receives feedback in the form
of Rewards or penalties so as we
discussed earlier in the robot case we
when it takes a step forward and it
doesn't Bang into a wall we will give it
a reward
and our goal is to maximize the total
reward so if it takes a step forward and
doesn't Bank into anything it will
eventually reach the goal
so it is a trial and error process
observing the consequences and adjusting
Its Behavior based on the rewards it
receives over time the agent learns to
identify the accidents that lead to the
highest rewards and avoid those that
lead to penalties so as we keep training
the what it will eventually learn what
decisions to take
autonomously
so it adapts to new situations and
environments and it will adjust Its
Behavior based on the feedback it
receives and
improving the performance
and it will become efficient decision
maker
which leads to better performance as
well so let's also look at some real
world use cases of reinforcement
learning so basically the example that
we covered is robotics we could perform
tasks such as grasping objects
navigating and interacting with humans
for example RL has been used to train
robots to play tennis
table tennis where the robot learns to
adjust its movement based on the
position of the ball
so let's look at another example of
which is the game plane so like the most
famous famous example is of Atari games
so like deepmind had launched uh
Italy game module
reinforcement learning has been applied
to game learning particularly in the
development of artificial Legends or we
can also talk about Blackjack we can
talk about Chess so a lot of games Atari
games uh alphago or computer program
developed by Google deepmind which is
reinforcement learning
to learn to play the game of Go at a
world-class level
also we can use reinforcement learning
for autonomous driving reinforcement
learning can be used to train autonomous
vehicles to make decisions in complex
and dynamic environments
for example reinforcement learning can
be used to train a self-driving car to
navigate through the traffic avoid
obstacles and make safe and efficient
driving decisions
also another uh very good example is of
personalized recommendations which is
basically Netflix or Google
recommendations
reinforcement learning can be used to
provide personalized recommendations to
user based on their preferences and
behavior for example we can use RL to
optimize the recommendations of a video
streaming service learning what content
to recommend
to the users
and to maximize user engagement and
satisfaction
so now we have learned about the agent
and the environment so now let's move on
to gymnasium which is a toolkit that
will help us simulate these environments
for our agent
so
basically it is a set
or a collection of environments or tasks
that can be used to test and develop
reinforcement learning algorithms these
environments are typically game like
with well-defined rules and a reward
structure making them useful for
evaluating and comparing different
reinforcement learning algorithms so
what I'll do is I'll head over to the
documentation page and show you the
different types of environments that are
available
so this is the introduction page
so basically it is just two lines of
code to set up an environment
and you can interact with the
environment as well so I encourage you
all to go and check out the
documentation and also explore the
different types of environments that are
available so we have a cardpool
environment we have a mountain car
also interesting environments we have a
car racing environment as well so
basically for gymnasium there is only
one single agent but if you want
multi-agents then we have another
Library called betting Zoo
we have a bipedal Walker here
and another
interesting environments is a blackjack
environment so in this tutorial I'll be
covering Blackjack environment
and another environment is a taxi
environment so basically this is like
our self-driving example
also we have a frozen lake environment
Cliff walking
these are all the very interesting
environments
so it could range from games like pong
or breakout to more complex simulations
like robotics or autonomous driving
environments are designed to be easy to
use and come with a standard interface
for interacting with the environment
now basically what all steps do we need
to start interacting with gymnasium
so let's check it out so we need to
define the environment that we want to
work in
we need to create an instance of the
environment so that that's what we did
here so basically we will use gym dot
make and use the environment that we
want
we will Define the agent's policy how it
decide which action to take interact
with the environment taking actions and
receiving Rewards update the agent's
policy based on the reward it receives
so just to uh go back we have an example
of a robot so when we take that example
and apply these rules we'll be able to
interact very easily so let me just show
you how we can do that so an environment
will be the warehouse environment an
instance of the environment will create
first
we'll Define the policy so in our case
the policy was that once the robot takes
a step forward
and if it doesn't
Clash into a wall or present Clash into
another word that is a successful step
and then we will reward it otherwise
we'll have to penalize it
so basically this is the fourth step we
have to update the agent's policy so
what we have to do is we need to updated
that once we take a successful tip you
need to keep taking successful steps and
you will and you will reach the end
and we'll keep repeating it until our
performance is satisfactory
let's learn some of the main Concepts we
will need in open AI gymnasium so the
first we have is observation and action
spaces
and as observation space is the set of
possible states that an agent can
observe in the environment an action
space is the set of possible actions
that an agent can take in an environment
so let's take the example of our robot
so what is the thing is that I have my
robot right here and the possible
actions that it can take is either it
can travel in the front
or it can travel to the right
or to the left
or take the
step back
so this is the possible action space
that can take also
in this case the observation space will
be
radio so it will be five
six
seven so action space is different than
the observation space
this is the full action space and the
observation space will be
it will change it up
this is action space this is the
observation space
let's look at episode an episode is a
complete run through of an environment
starting from the initial State and
continuing until a terminal state is
reached so let's look at that in our
example as well so I have my robot right
here and I wanted to reach here
so this would be an episode and I can
train the robot to run multiple episodes
so it will start at a particular
position and it will reach this terminal
position so that will be one episode it
will start there and could go in here as
well so basically this could be a
terminal location or it could this could
be the start location and this could be
the terminal location so these are all
the different episodes that we have
now each episode is composed of sequence
of States action and Rewards
wrapper a wrapper is a tool in open air
gym that allows you to modify an
environment's Behavior without changing
its code so we'll look into that later
on wrappers can be used to add features
such as time limits reward shaping and
action masking
Benchmark openai gym provides a set of
Benchmark environments which are
standardized tasks that can be used to
evaluate and compare reinforcement
learning algorithms so if we have
multiple algorithms for a particular
environment or a problem we can use the
Benchmark to compare them
we are done with the basics of
reinforcement learning and also we have
learned the agent environment and
everything that is needed to get started
so now let's implement the game of
Blackjack uh using gymnasium first let's
get
introduced to the game of blackjack
so what are the basic rules so the basic
rules is that I need I have I will have
two cards and the dealer will have two
cards now in this scenario both will be
AI players so the thing is that uh at
each turn I will have to decide that I
need a new card or do I want to keep my
current set of cards but the dealer has
to keep playing until he until the E
reaches over 17 the sum of the card that
is over 17. and
if I have to win I need to be a bigger
number than my sum of the cards have to
be greater than the Dealer's card so
let's go over all the basic rules of
blackjack this game is played with one
or more decks of standard playing cards
each dealer is dealt two cards and the
dealer is also day two cards with one
card face down the value of each card is
determined by its rank cases can be
worth 1 or 11 face cards King queens and
Jacks Are Over 10. and all other cards
are their face value
players have the option to hit and take
additional cards to improve their hand
or stand and keep the current hand the
dealer must hit until their hand has a
value of 17 or more
if a player's hand goes over 21 they
bust and lose the game if the Dealer's
hand goes over 21 the player wins the
game if neither the player nor the
dealer bursts the hand with the highest
total value that is less than or equal
to 21 wins so basically these are the
rules
now let's head over to the gymnasium
documentation and check out how
Blackjack is implemented
so here we are in the gymnascent
documentation
now let's check out the action space and
observation space here
so basically we need to import Blackjack
V1 to create the Blackjack environment
yeah this is the rules that we discussed
now action space the action space is one
comma in the range of 0 comma 1
indicating whether to stick or hit
so it's
the players decision
but the dealer has to keep playing
the observation consists of three Tuple
containing the players current sum the
value of the dealers one card one to ten
where one is is and whether the player
holds a usable is one or zero basically
this will be the observation space
our starting space will be
4 between 4 and 11. tiller card has two
and eleven and other usable yes if I
have a usable yes or no what will be the
rewards in this particular reinforcement
learning problem so we'll have win game
as plus one lose game as minus one raw
game is zero and win game with natural
backjack plus 1.5 if natural is true and
plus one if natural is false so
basically this is another type of set
that is the natural environment
so basically we can understand that
so if natural is true
whether to give an additional reward for
starting with a natural back Jack that
is starting with an Ace and 10. so we
can specify that when we set up the
environment
now let's see how we can implement it in
Google collab
now we've covered the basics of
blackjack now let's understand how we
can solve this game of blackjack
so let's suppose discuss a book that is
very popular regarding to blanket it's
called reinforcement learning and
introduction by Richard Sutton and
Andrew Bartow it covers the basic
applications of reinforcement learning
and also there is a chapter on Blackjack
and it also covers other games
and they have modeled it a Markov
decision process and how a reaction
infuses the outcome of the game
now also they explain how reinforcement
learning algorithms can be used to learn
optimal policies for playing back Jack
based on maximizing the expected return
over the long term so now this feels
very complicated but this is the
beginner course you do not need to learn
this once this course is over and you
still have a curiosity you can go check
out this book
and because why should you check out
this book because it presents several
approaches to solving the Blackjack
problem
including Monte Carlo methods and
temporary difference learning
it also covers value functions and
policy Improvement which are a very
Advanced topics so maybe we will create
a course on that but as this is the
beginner course you do not need to know
all these
so let's start with the basic
implementation
what I'll be doing is I'll be importing
the libraries that will be needing so
let's do click install
so I'll be copying this multiple times
thank you
please do
not plot live
then let's do numpy
C1 so basically number is used for data
manipulation
so as we import I'll just explain to you
when we import what each library is used
for
tqdm
we are in gymnasium
equal to equal to
0.27.0 so basically this is the LTS
support long term support version
and let's do matplotlift in line so as
you all know when Matlab is used it
opens a new window but in collab Google
collab there is no window so basically
the plots should be in line so basically
we'll do this
percentage match.lib inline
so it will show all the plots below the
cell
so yeah it's done let's do pip install
yeah so I already have it installed but
in my machine it will take some time to
install by uh till it get installed
let's also import all the necessary
method that we will need so from
collections
I will import default
so why I am using a defaulting is
because it allows us to access keys
without checking that if the value is
accessed its value exists
from import
lib Dot
Pi plot
as PLT
so this is I just also write down why
we'll be using this
house access to
an
we find the keys
the keys that do not exist
so if you check for us instead of us
having to always check if that key is
exists it will just take it for us
so we'll be using this for
drawing plots
from matte plot lib dot patches so
basically this is for creating shapes
to draw shapes
now let's import numpy so as number is
very popular
basically numpy is for array
manipulation and image manipulation
data an array manipulation
let's do input c bond C1 is a very
popular data visualization Library
has SNS
and from tqdm so basically this is for a
loader so whatever uh training that
happens it will show it as a loader so
it will be very easy to understand the
training progress
so I think we have completed the
installation of the basic libraries
now let's
show let's so what I'll be doing is I'll
be using the gym that make command to
create our environment so it will be EnV
is equal to
gym so I have already imported the
gymnasium okay I forgot to import it
let me import it as well so from import
gymnasium
as a gym
now let's do gym dot make so our
environment name is
Blackjack V1
black and Jack
B1 and
what I'll be doing is I'll be setting
the Sab parameter to true what is Sab
parameter it is like the natural
environment basically the default state
of certain and
the book that we discussed
so what I'll be doing is and also I'll
be setting the render mode is equal to
RGB gray because I'll be showing you the
training threads so exactly what is the
position of the card at that particular
moment in training
so that will be interesting to watch
that is why I'll set this render mode to
RGB array now let's go and see how we
can set up the environment oh so how
will we observing the environment what
I'll be doing is I'll be setting this
as let's observe the environment
yeah so we'll be using the env.start
method to observe an uh episode so
basically we discussed what is an
episode it is basically
uh all the steps that it takes for me to
reach from the starting point to the end
point once basically that is an episode
and for uh setting an episode we do it
as observation
comma info is equal to EnV dot reset so
basically we use the reset method to
reset the full board or reset the
particular environment and we'll be
keeping done as well because we have
just started
the training so let's do let's get some
comments
we said the environment
that the first observation
so and what will be the output of this
so observation is equal to it is a tuple
and as we have discussed it before it
will be 16 9 and false so what is this
so basically this is my hand what I have
been dealt this is the dealers and
and this is the number of if do I have
an ace so I do not have an ace at the
start so that is why I have got the
output as false
so it will it is a Boolean and uh it is
like uh the this value represents that
if I have a is usable
without busting so yeah that is the
thing you I can have an ace but I can
also bust as well so this is a an ace
which is usable and without busting
so let's write that down as well so what
is this output let's write
thank you
this is our Tuple consisting of three
values
so the first value is the
players current sum
the second will be
value of dealers
face up card
third
it will be Boolean
weather
the player holds
holds a usable s
and what is the usable is where
it is
usable
if it counts
and without busting
basically that is
let's see how we can execute that
so for executing action
first we'll receive our first
observation should be basically that
will be the starting space
so let me go into then after that we'll
be using the env.step and we'll be
giving the action to interact with the
environment so in if we take one example
of the Blackjack it will be that if I
want to take a new card or do I want to
keep my current set of cards that will
be passed in the action
this function takes an action as an
input and executes it in the environment
because that action changes the state of
the environment it returns four useful
variables to us these are next state
this is the observation that the agent
will receive after taking the action it
will also give us the reward
the agent will receive after taking the
action either this environment has
terminated or it will give us truncated
that if the episode ended early
the time limit is reached this is a
dictionary that contains additional
information about the environment the
next state reward terminated and
truncated variables are self-explanatory
but the info variable requires some
additional explanation this variable
contains a dictionary that might have
some extra information about the
environment but in blackjack V1
environment you can ignore it for
example in Atari environments the info
dictionary has ale dot live key that
tells us how many lives the agent has
left if the agent has zero lives then
the episode is over so basically these
are the four values that are important
after we take a step so let's see how we
can take a step now
so let's take
a new cell and
let's take the action so
action
is equal to EnV dot action underscore
space dot sample
now what is this so this is a sample
action that will be taking sample a
random action
basically this is the training Loop so
that's why we are taking a sample action
all valid
actions
now we have hash
action is equal to 1 and what we'll do
is we'll execute
execute the action
so basically how we will be executing it
so we'll be taking observations
so we discuss all the parameters here
right so we'll be taking all the four
parameters we'll be having reward
here will be having terminated
truncated
and info so we can ignore info but I'll
be taking info just in case
step and action so action is the sample
action from here
to execute the action
also will be receiving enforce and
received
info after taking it
after taking the step
so what will be the output if we run
this so the sample output will be
observation is equal to so basically we
have learned what this Tuple means this
is a 24 this is my current sum so
basically I have gone bust
now also first I do not have any usable
basically this is just a sample start so
I have some values here so I'll explain
to you all these values
so and reward is equal to
minus 1.0 so basically I have lost
also terminated will be true
is equal to true we have truncated
false and hash info
is equal to blank so yeah this this is
how it's going to be for this particular
one sample step
so once we get terminated is equal to
true what do we do then the current
episode we have to reset so if
terminated
I had to take a text
terminated is equal to true or
yeah we should stop the current episode
and begin a new one
using
env.reset so basically I've talked about
this method before as well
okay and this is what this is a single
action that we take in this particular
environment
now let's build our agent
so now we have completed the basic setup
of the environment and our agent now
let's understand the approach that we'll
be using to solve like that so let's
look at the Epsilon greedy strategy this
is a very Optimum strategy to solve
Blackjack so let's understand it in this
strategy the agent takes an action that
is either the best action based on the
current policy with a probability of 1
minus Epsilon or a random action with a
probability of Epsilon this approach
balances the exploitation of the current
best policy with exploration of new
policies which can lead to better
rewards in the long term so basically it
is a very
strict policy either I take the current
best policy current best
approach or action or either a random
action so how we'll set the policy let's
let's look at that later but let's
understand the Epsilon greedy strategy
in the context of blackjack the Epsilon
greedy strategy can be applied to
determine whether the player should hit
or standards at each step of the game
the agent that is the player can choose
to take the action that is either
recommended by the current policy or it
is a random action the policy is learned
over time by updating the action value
estimates of each state action pair
based on the rewards received during the
game
as the game is played repeatedly the
agent learns the optimal policy that
maximizes the expected rewards so
basically we as we keep on running uh
the the iterations and the agent keeps
learning it will understand the optimum
policy that will maximize our expected
reward initially the agent May explore
by taking random actions to discover new
strategies however as the game
progresses the agent will start to
exploit the best known policy which
should maximize the expected reward over
time so this is the approach that we'll
be using
now let's build our agent using this
approach the Epsilon greedy strategy
approach so let's take a code cell and
create our class so basically we'll
create a blackjack agent class
and let's do diff so we'll Define the
initial Constructor that is the default
Constructor and what all parameters do
we need for this so we will take the
self parameter and take learning rate
so basically this will be passed as
Epsilon
it will be a float
let's take initial
Epsilon
will be a float as well
let's take Epsilon decay
it will be of float as well let's take
final Epsilon
this will be a float as well and let's
take the discount
Factor
let me include
and this will be 0.95 in this case so we
have completed the initial converter
let's
move award and create our
initial let's complete the initial
Constructor
Q underscore values
is equal to default X so we will be
using default X because we do not want
to always check if that key exists it
will be a Lambda method Lambda mission
NP dot zeros yeah so we can just
initialize it as
in P dot zeros
let's set it at EnV dot action space
Dot N
now let's create some
comments as well just for explanation so
what are we going to do here we are
going to initialize
our RL so whenever I say RL it is a it
is reinforcement learning agent with
empty dictionary
of State action values
this is the Q values
learning rate
Epsilon
although arguments let's understand all
the arguments as well
so we'll be calculating the
learning rate
so I think these are pretty self uh
explanatory let me just explain to you
the discount Factor so the learning rate
is the learning rate itself the initial
Epsilon value Epsilon Decay is the Decay
for Epsilon and this will be the final
Epsilon value and the discount factor is
something that needs to be understood
let's understand the risk factor
the discount factor for computing the Q
value so I'll explain to you what the Q
value is let's just first complete the
basic
class of our agent
key value this is the approach that we
are going to be using using Q learning
so solving Blackjack using key learning
so now let's complete our
Constructor
so basically this is the learning rate
thank you
self dot discount Factor
is equal to Discount Factor
and root cells dot Epsilon
is equal to initial Factor
no second Epsilon is equal to initial
Epsilon I'm at
LG says Dot Epsilon decay
is equal to it's not this is one single
equal
self dot final Epsilon
equal to final underscore Epsilon
let's do the training errors as well
training error
is equal to blank array
now let's create another method that is
the get action method
basically I need to complete the
intentation let's do that let me
complete the indentation
yeah and this looks good
this is the Tuple that we discussed the
observation Tuple that we'll be getting
so it's intendable
and the output will be an integer
so this will be the get action method
where we need to define the policy so
if NP Dot random dot random we'll be
doing two random
is less than self dot Rand cell dot
Epsilon
so I think I made a mistake here
and I could do return EnV dot action
underscore sample so we'll be taking the
sample action instead of taking the
correct action
yeah else if the probability is is good
enough
let me take
the return of
hint
and P dot Arc Max
self dot Q value so basically this is
the Q values that will be using here so
I'll explain to you in just some seconds
if we complete all the methods right so
let's let's give it some parameters here
so basically this is this will return
Returns the best action
with
probability
1 minus Epsilon
otherwise
random action with probability X2 for
exploration so yeah this is the
basically the approach that we
understood before
ensure exploration
okay this is done let's create another
method first
depending what other Q value is so
basically let me just write it down here
so the Q value
function
is used to estimate
the optimizer
action
to take
in each state
the optimal action in a state is the one
it is the one
that maximizes
the expected long
tell me what so basically we have
understood the Epsilon approach so
basically this is how we will be
maximizing it now this is a bit
complicated the equation there is a Arc
Max which will return the maximizing
value so I
encourage you guys to go and just
understand the logic behind it it's
pretty complicated but let me this is
basically
the optimal action that we have to take
in each state basically this will be
calculated for us in our
in our game
yeah let's let's move ahead now we need
to complete the
update method so let's complete that we
have our
Dev update
and it will have self
observation
you see this is the observation tube
excuse me
so like I I might be having some error
so when we compile it we'll get to know
all this
excellent
let's do reward
rewards load
into terminated
Boolean and do next observation
as again a tupel interval so this will
be
in network transformation
so we've understood what the Q function
is so basically we'll be updating the
queue function
so let's understand it future
Q value is equal to
not terminated
into NP dot Max
self dot Q values of next observation
so we'll be taking the
Q value of the next observation and
multiplying it with the terminating
method so if it is terminated then
we have to start again if it is not then
we do not we do not need to calculate
this
is equal to
so we have the reward
basically this is the method that is the
function
it also explaining to you how we
calculate it
count Factor
into
future
Q value
minus
basically this is the literal formula
that we used to calculate it I'll
explain it to you
let's let's go ahead and complete these
methods
observation of action
so yeah this is done the Q measured Q
value is done
let's do the training mod
now we need to update the Q value now
so we have completed the difference now
let's do the self dot Q values
of observation and of the action
2D array is equal to
self dot Q values
so basically this is what we have to do
again Q
underscore values
I'll be copying this right here
plus self dot LR so this is the learning
rate into the temporal difference
and this will be self Dot
training error
dot opened
temporal difference
so yeah it's done now let's complete the
last method that the DK Epsilon
comma self dot Epsilon
minus Epsilon decay
so basically we have completed our class
Blackjack agent
so now we've completed the class
of our agent so we will Define all the
actions that the agent can perform now
let's
see
the training of the agent so let's start
the training
we will be training it one episode at a
time
so let's do the parameters for servers
we'll keep the learning rate
and 0.01 this is the learning rate
we have the episodes
is equal to
100 000 episode so we can change it like
I'll just keep it 100 000 because that's
will give us a very good trained agent
but I will just reduce it for the
tutorial
this is the standard that we should keep
if you want to create a real world
agent
so let's do it on decay
equal to start
episodes by two so we reduce the
expiration one time we wanted to take
the appropriate
path without having to explore too much
so this will basically reduce it
then we have the final Epsilon
basically this is where we need to get
by the end of the training let's create
our agent this is this are these are all
the parameters the hyper parameters
foreign
okay integrate it is equal to start
start Epsilon is one and basically we
need to get to 0.1 from 1.
now we have Epsilon d k is equal to
Epsilon d k
let's pass that now also let's give it
the final Epsilon
yeah so this is the agent that we have
initialized
so now let's turn the training let's
turn to training now so basically we
have completed the agent setup now now
let's start the training so what I'll do
is I'll just set up the environment
basically
NV is equal to Jim dot wrappers
dot record so we will be recording all
the statistics and I will just show you
after the training how the agent
improves over time so we'll be plotting
some charts as well so let me complete
the training part first and then we'll
talk about what uh the training
has how the training has improved over
time and what kind of all the statistics
would mean so we'll be recording
charts and also I will give you the
statistics
so we have n episodes
and episodes okay so it will be
recording the statistics for our episode
now let's do that so we have uh 100 000
episodes let's make it 10 for this
tutorial just so that it will run fast
now so I will also output the uh the
environment at particular point so I
will uh so every time that a card is
dealt or anything that is decision is
made by the agent we'll be plotting that
particular uh environment and see the
what is happening in real time so I'll
be doing that as well so it's like
watching live play live poker in real
time
so let's do that let's let's do that now
we do n with the reset now why do we do
n mean dot reset because as we discussed
after every episode we need to reset the
environment because I have traveled from
one point to another point I need to
reset the environment now
okay let's do done is equal to pause
because we need to complete the
challenge we need to get to the end
point
let's do clear output now I need to
import
so what I'll be doing is for every
episode I I will be clearing the output
because I'm only interested in the
current episode and what is happening
right now in real time so I'll import
IPython display import clear output
basically this is what I need to import
so basically for every episode this will
clear the output now let's complete
third training for one episode this will
be play one episode
let's do while not done so this is false
so while we are not done let's run this
Loop let's do action
equal to agent dot get action
of observation
let's do next underscore OBS comma
reward
comma terminated this is all the
information that we will get after
making a particular step
is to be truncated
and it will be info
equal to EnV dot step
let's update now let's do agent dot
update
we'll be passing all these parameters so
we have to pass observation action
reward
terminated and the next position
next observation mistake
frame so basically I will be rendering
the frame so
at particular instance what is happening
we can just output that as well
so I'll be doing that here frame is
equal to env.render I'll do PLT dot IM
show frame
for prom pipe dot I'll be showing you
the exact location of the cards and
exact position of the cards and exactly
what is happening in real time
now what we have to do is we have to
check if that episode is terminated so
how will we know that we will have a
parameter called Terminator or we have
truncated so translated is that we have
a bust other Terminator is that the time
limit is over
so observation is equal to next
observation
and we have to do agent
so oh yeah I'm starting to follow we
need to do agent dot DK Epsilon
so over time it will get smarter
so yeah this is it
so I'll be using uh
the package called annotations because
I'll be using subscripts in my methods
so I got an error here now let's run it
and check again
so if you are also getting an error
make sure to
import the package annotations now
everything should run fine
let's do it
Yeah so basically this is another error
basically this is like running and it is
not defined so it is
defined so why it is saying that it is
going to find
okay it should be equal to basically
these things happen
yeah this one's fine now let's try this
yeah color cement equal to equal to
where is that
your let's see
what I can do
record episode
basically these things happen so
there is nothing in the gymnasium dot
wrappers so it is wrappers not wrapper
also has no attribute record episode
statistics so it is happy
yeah this episode statistics
and yes
defined so this is not OB this is our
OBS this is the observation space
yeah now we're gonna attempting to add
episode when they already exist so we'll
see why that happens
everything is done let's run everything
let's do run all
now if you get some errors just make
sure to check out the intendations
or I'll just link my google caller
notebook in the description you guys can
go and check it out
because there were a lot of
intendation issues before running it so
yeah now that's it
so as you can see for every episode we
are able to visualize it so there is a
well if it is a 21 then it's a draw you
both have 21.
you'll see it is 12.
it's pretty fun to watch
so now currently I have set the episode
100 000 I can change it then keep it as
10. but I'm just gonna let it drain so
once that is done I'll just come back
and let's just
visualize the training part then because
we need to understand the error losses
and we need to understand the
uh policy that we have used
while this is running let's just
complete the visualization code so what
I'll be doing is we'll do rolling length
so we'll be understanding all the
parameters and all the data relating to
our policy and understand what is the
appropriate amount of episodes that we
can use now so the loss function
will plot it and we'll understand the
trajectory as well so let's do that so
what I've done is I've set the rolling
length is 500 and I have done the figure
size here so I let me just complete the
code and I'll explain to you everything
what we've done so yeah I'll just give
it as five
which is subplots not sublots
excess of
zero dot set title so that we'll just
get the title as episode rewards so what
how does the reward change in each
episode
and we have got it let's plot that
episode Rewards
so now let's do reward
the score moving the score average
equal to
NP dot convolve we will plot the control
graph
and look NP dot array
EnV dot return queue
dot flatten so we'll flatten it
Dot Latin dot comma and P dot ones
rolling length
and let's do mode is equal to valid
and let's do rolling length divided by
Rolling lens this will be for every 500
iterations we are doing this
now this is completed let's do axis of 0
Dot Plot
range
Len
reward moving average
foreign
average of the reward now what I'll be
doing is I'll be plotting it against the
reward moving average
so yeah
that that value
this is the value here so we are going
to plot it now let's do excess of one
two is the y-axis got set title
should lens set
so lens this is done let's do length
underscore moving underscore average
this will be our variable this should be
the same it will do a corn evaluation
we'll do NP dot Cornwall so I'll explain
to you why we use the Cornwall method as
well
so basically this is we need to do not
planted
this is not flatten then we need to do
NP dot ones
rolling length again and more is equal
to same so instead of valid we'll do
same now
next to put dot
and we'll do same
close the brackets
divide this by Rolling length
Dot Plot
range
length
training error moving average where it
will stick
so yeah we have at the Box
training error
score moving this code average
comma
training underscore
underscore moving
underscore
average
so this is it this look PLT dot tight
layout
so basically I have completed the
training
visualizing of the training parameters
and how the graph looks like so what
I'll do is I'll just wait for the
training to complete and then I will
explain to you the graph
so the training is complete now let's
look at the different parameters that we
have plotted so they have three
different types of charts let's
understand each one of them so first one
we have is episode Rewards
so the episode Rewards
in our case of solving Blackjack an
episode is uh can be defined as a game
of blackjack played from start to finish
and the episode rewards is the total sum
of the rewards obtained during that game
it could be the sum of the numbers of
wins and losses and we can add any
bonuses or penalties for certain actions
so as you can see for each episode
there is a very drastic change in the
rewards
so basically this is very interesting to
watch like this it's not a flat line
basically we do not have any range bound
movement between it it just uh just is
too volatile it just keeps changing so
this is very interesting to watch
so now let's look at the episode lens
compared which is plotted against each
episode
so basically this is
one complete sequence of playing a hand
taking a hit or a stand and receiving
the result now the length of an episode
would depend on the rules of the game
the number of players and other factors
so in our game it could be just two
players but you can have more number of
players as well and uh in a game of
blackjack you could consist of uh it
would consist of a single hand or
multiple hands with different lengths of
each episode
so basically you can see in our case it
would be more than one only
but
it doesn't go over too so basically
everywhere you can find between 1.4 1.3
basically 1.3 and 1.4 so uh each episode
is just
between 1.3 and 1.4 that is also very
interesting to watch
let's look at the training error the
training error is a measure of how well
a model is performing on the training
data now in our context of solving
Blackjack using pulani the training
error would be difference between the
expected value of the queue function and
the actual Q values obtained during the
training the goal of queue learning is
to minimize this error and converge to
Optimal Q values that maximize the
expected reward a high training error
indicates that the model is not learning
effectively and adjustments may be
needed to the algorithm or training data
so as you can see at around 3000 around
this is pretty good
our training error is pretty low
now after 3000 it goes pretty high
so that's it
now we are done with our training of the
Blackjack agent and we have uh
successfully solved the blackjack game
using the Q learning algorithm now let's
quickly revise all the things that we
have learned while we solve when we
started solving black effect
so we started with the reinforcement
learning basics
then I also explained to you the role of
an agent what exactly constitutes an
environment what each action is
and how do we keep track of each action
each state that the agent is currently
in then we also learned about the
observation
aspect and also how we use rewards to
keep track of a successful step and also
give penalty to the agent when
it makes a wrong step
so basically we have covered that then
I'll also explain to you the real world
use cases of reinforcement learning we
so basically there is robotics gameplay
autonomous driving
personalized recommendations
then we started by uh with the gymnasium
Library basically it gives us a
collection of environments that can be
used to test and develop reinforcement
learning algorithms so here we have made
use of the Blackjack environment
then we started with the setting
then we started the setup for the
gymnasium environment also I've walked
you through all the
processes that we need to successfully
solve any problem so this is true for
any reinforcement learning problem
then I also explained to you the main
concepts of open air gymnasium
so we started with observation and
action Spaces episode what is the
wrapper benchmark
now we start with the introduction to
the Blackjack game so basically here are
the basic rules the game is played with
one or more decks of standard playing
cards each player is built two cards and
the dealer is also Del two cards with
one card face down
the value of each card is determined by
its rank Aces can be worth 1 or 11 face
cards that is kings queens and Jacks
about 10 and all other face cards are
worth their face value and basically
we have the option to hit and take
additional cards to improve our hand or
stand and keep the current hand the
dealer must hit until their event has a
value of 17 or more if a player's hand
goes over 21 they bust and they lose the
game if the dealers hand goes over 21
the player wins the game if neither the
player nor the dealer bus the hand with
the highest total value that is less
than or equal to 21 wins the game
so this is an example now we have
learned about the action space the
observation space the starting space
about the rewards and how what
constitutes an episode and how does an
episode end so we have the termination
conditions here
now we have started with the solving of
blackjack I also introduced you to a
very good book that is reinforcement
learning and introduction
by Richard Sutton and Andrew Bartow
basically this is the
summary of the book
now we started with the
installing of the so basically we have
started with the installing of all the
gym of the all the libraries that we
need for the tutorial so this is
then we started with our
import statements so we have imported
all the libraries that we need now here
is where we have
created our Blackjack V1 environment
then we have reset the environment and
started with the first observation
then we have the observation
Tuple so basically this is the Tuple
now then we start executing the actions
we have the next state reward terminated
State truncated State and the info
basically this is the step
now we have used the Epsilon greedy
strategy to solve blackjack
so what is the Epsilon strategy in this
strategy the agent takes an action that
is either the best action based on the
current policy with the probability of
one minus Epsilon or a random action
with the probability of Epsilon this
approach balances the exploitation of
the current best policy with exploration
of new policies which can lead to better
rewards in the longer run
basically this was the Epsilon it is
strategy that we use also I have
explained to you the uh what is the Q
value so this is the class for our
Blackjack agent we have all the methods
we have the getaction method update
method
now we started with the training so we
have set up some hyper parameters here I
have also explained in detail what each
parameter does so you can just play
around with these
now we start with the training Loop we
have the episode we have created a
number of episodes
now we what we do is while not done we
play the episode and basically this is
an error I got so we started with the
rolling length
so this is other plotting of the graphs
that we did here
so this was the code for that and also I
explained to you the
oil what all the graphs that we have
plotted here
so now we have solved Blackjack using Q
learning also now let's look at some
other methods that we can solve
blackjack
so the first one is Monte Carlo method
Monte Carlo is a model 3 method that
learns from experience in the context of
blackjack Monte Carlo methods involves
playing the game several times and
keeping track of the rewards obtained
for each action the agent then updates
its value function based on the average
of the rewards obtained for each state
action pair
Monte Carlo methods are suitable for
problem like episodic tasks like
Blackjack so you can use gymnasium and
try this approach as well now let's look
at the other approach temporal
difference method it is another model 3
method that learns from experience in
the TD learning the agent updates its
value function based on the difference
between the predicted and the actual
reward TD methods are suitable for
problems with continuous tasks like
backjack
Q learning is something that we've
already solved Blackjack but let's just
quickly revise watch Q learning queue
learning is a model free reinforcement
learning algorithm that learns the
optimal policy by updating its Q values
for each state pair the agent selects
the action with the highest Q value for
a given state
Q learning is suitable for problems with
finite States and actions like Blackjack
the fourth method that we have is deep Q
Networks so basically we will be solving
so in the next uh example we'll be
solving card pole problem that is like
an Atari game where you have to balance
the card pole and we'll be using deep
cure networks so I'll also explain in
detail what are the DQ networks so let's
look at the brief deep Q networks
combined reinforcement learning with
deep neural networks the eqns learn the
optimal policy by approximating the Q
values using a deep neural network
dqns are suitable for problems with high
dimensional State spaces like image
based games
so it's like an image so these are
suitable for image based games
now the fifth example that we have is
active critic example actor critic is a
model based reinforcement learning
algorithm that uses the two networks and
actor and a Critic the actor Network
selects the actions while the critic
Network evaluates the actions taken by
the actor
is suitable for problems with continuous
action spaces like that
so these are all the different
approaches that you can use to solve
Blackjack and I highly encourage
you all to use gymnasium and try these
approaches so you will find uh you will
have to use some math for that also you
will find that online as well but uh
these are the different approaches that
you can use
so now let's go to another example where
we'll be using the environment of the
card pool so now let's understand what
what is the carpool environment and then
we'll understand about deep Q Networks
so in the carpool environment we have an
agent that can decide two actions moving
the card right or moving the cut left
right or left so the pole attached to it
stays upright so as you can see in this
clip
we have to balance the pole and these
are can be random actions so it could
just tilt left twice or it could go to
the left five times and it could go to
the right one so we need to have
all the possibilities covered here
you can find more information about the
environment at the gymnasium website so
uh I have also linked the website link
here
now let's uh look in detail as the agent
observes the current state of the
environment and chooses an action the
environment transitions to a new state
and also returns a reward that indicates
the consequences of the action
in this task rewards are plus one for
every incremental time step and the
environment terminates if the of the
pole Falls over too far or the card
moves over 2.4 units away from the
center
so basically we do not have allow we
cannot allow the pole to fall 2.4 units
away from the center
and for every
incremental time step we will have first
one reward so we have to maximize the
number of time we can balance this
cardboard
this means better performing scenarios
will run for longer duration
accumulating larger return
the cardboard task is designed so that
the inputs to the agent are four real
values representing the environmental
State position velocity Etc we take
these four inputs without any scaling
and pass them through a small fully
connected network with two outputs one
for each action
the network is trained to predict the
expected value for each action given the
input State the action with the highest
expected value is then chosen so now
let's look uh in detail like how we can
implement this network as well
now let's look at all the
methods that we'll be using from PI
torch so the first is the neural
networks which is
imported using taurus.nn now in general
this model provides tools for building
neural networks it includes a wide range
of layer type wide range of layer types
such as fully connected layers
convolutional layers and recurrent
layers as well as activation functions
and loss functions
now let's look at in perspective of a
dqn the torch.nn model is used to define
our neural network architecture
now let's look at the other method that
is the optimization method
now this module provides a range of
optimization algorithms for training
neural networks it includes classic
optimization algorithms such as
stochastic gradient descent as well as
more advanced algorithms like Adam and
RMS prop but let's look at in context of
the dqn we'll be using tors.optimization
module
to optimize our neural our Network
weights
now next is taurus.autograd which is
this model now this model in the context
of dqn is used to compute gradients
during back propagation
this module provides automatic
differentiation functionality which is
essential for training neural networks
via black propagation it enables pythons
to automatically compute gradients of a
loss function with respect to all the
parameters of the network allowing
optimization algorithms to adjust the
parameters in order to minimize the loss
now let's import the modules that we
need so the first is the gymnasium
classic control
let's import that
basically that conver that
contains the model that we need the card
pole V1 model
let's install that flip install
gymnasium
classic underscore control
this is the name so now let's also
import all the other methods that we
need so let's import import nasium
as Jim
Port math so basically these are all the
inbuilt models matches inbuilt
let's do a random random asterism
put matplotlib this chatting Library
plot lib
it's used for making charts
let's import
not plot
lib dot Pi plot spld deciding one of the
most
common code line in
python
quote name Tuple and deck so basically
we'll be using this data structures to
manage
the training
tools import count these are will be
using this now let's import all the
torch modules
or torch input
Taurus dot NN has nn
laser torch.optim
um yes optim
import
towards dot NN dot functional
functional as f
now let's also create our environment so
basically this will be gym.make
cardpool
cut Pole
V1
now also let's set the inline
setting for matplotlib
nine in
at plot lib dot net I think I forgot to
import
yeah let's let's write that code over
because I think we can directly make it
in line now issues if it is we are in
collab if we're in Google collab we want
pi plot
thought to be plotted as inline so that
will be displayed below the cell
so here let's do if is I python so
basically this is Google collab again
from IPython
input display because we need the
display
to display the charts
let's do plt.in
also if you do not have a GPU we can
just add a condition as well and if you
do have GPU then we can increase the
training so let's set the variable if we
have a GPU
and this Cuda is
torch.oda dot so basically this is the
method to
understand if we do have a GPU available
and you can just go to settings
in tools you need to go to settings
in the Google editor
I think in the runtime I think you need
to send it to runtime yeah
so it will be change and time type and
you can just add a GPU or so I will do
that I'll do that as well so it will
basically give us a lot more computing
power
so now we've completed the basic in
code where we have imported all the
libraries that we would need now let's
look at another concept that is very
important in this in this example or to
solve cardboard so now let's look at the
replay memory so what is replay memory
it is a technique used in reinforcement
learning to store and manage the
experience of an agent during training
the idea is to store the agent's
experiences as a sequence of State
action reward next state tuples so
basically we have this four values which
are collected as the agent interacts
with the environment during training
these experiences are used to update the
agent's policy and value function
so basically this is we collect all the
actions performed by
our agent
now let's look at what the importance of
the replay memory the replay memory
allows the agent to learn from past
experiences by randomly sampling a batch
of experiences from the memory buffer
rather than just learning from the most
recent experience so it's like the uh so
we instead of just learning from our
recent experience we take a sample of
all the past experiences and make a
decision based on that this helps us to
reduce the correlation between
subsequent experiences
which can improve the stability and
convergence of the learning algorithm in
addition by storing experiences in a
buffer the agent can reuse past
experiences to update his policy and
value function multiple times which can
further improve learning efficiency
the replay memory is typically
implemented as a fixed size buffer or
queue that stores the most recent
experiences when the buffer is full new
experiences override the oldest
experiences in the buffer
during training a batch of experiences
is randomly sampled from the buffer and
used to update the agent's policy and
value function this process is repeated
iteratively until the agent converges to
an optimal policy so basically this is
an example it's a basic thing it's a
very basic concept we
store all of the training data until the
queue is full
and the buffer memory that we have will
keep using it as we go ahead
yeah that's the concept
now let's look at how we'll use the
concept of Replay memory in to implement
our dqn algorithm
so what what we'll do is let's
understand that so we'll store the
transitions that the agent observes
allowing us to reuse this iterator by
sampling from it randomly the
transitions that build up a batch are
Decor related
it has been shown that this greatly
stabilizes and improves the DQ and
training procedure so now let's also
understand how we will implement this in
code so we'll have two classes one is
the first will be transition class it is
a name Tuple representing a single
transition in our environment basically
this is our
sample input so this will be represent
one state
it essentially Maps State action pairs
to the next
State reward result which is the state
being the screen difference image as
described later on
Nano X will be the replay class a cyclic
buffer of bounded size that holds the
transitions observed recently it also
implements a DOT sample method for
selecting a random batch of transitions
for training
let's Implement our replay memory class
so the first will be the transition
state that we have which is a tuple it
is the named
pupil
by the name of transition
and then we'll have
state
action
next state
and reward
we have to close it
yeah basically this is our
transaction Tuple now let's also create
our class which is the replay memory
class
so it will be a class
we called replay
memory
then object
let's do def underscore underscore
init
ially self comma capacity
and then we'll have self dot memory so
basically this will be done full memory
buffer
so it is equal to a deck
I don't know how you pronounce it but I
pronounce it as it could be called as DQ
also depending on the
X India max length
is equal to capacity
so basically this is our max length
after that it all it will overflow and
then we'll reset it
diff push
so we'll push one
transition into this
memory always here this is the memory
will have self
comma RX we'll pass some arguments as
well
so basically it let's just also comment
okay
save so I think it is double so yeah
save a transition
save
translation
and let's do
yeah
self plot memory
not append
transition
star arcs
yeah it is no
single quote
okay so basically this will append to
our memory
let's create another method of the
sample
where this method will help us sample
our buffer remember before memory
we'll have self comma batch size
so we'll have a capacity and the batch
size so if the capacity could be 50 and
the bad size will be 10.
so this is how it will be
let's do return
random
what sample
okay
self Dot memory comma
batch size
also Define underscore underscore length
will give us the length of the buffer at
any point
return length of size dot memory
so yeah I think we have done it
completed let's also block to the code
again so we have
defined the transition Tuple
and replay memory class
now we have four Fields here State
action next state
and I think I need to do it like this
yeah Rewards
oh I think it is reward yeah
and we will have the class as well so
we'll have the post method
this method takes in
a state which is State action next state
Tuple
as it input and creates a transition
object from it and append it to the deck
if the deck is already at maximum
capacity the oldest element in the deck
is removed so this is how the append
method works let's look at the sample
method
this method randomly samples a batch of
batch size which is the batch size
parameter that we have passed
experiences from the deck and returns
them as a list
so this is the sampling method let's
look at the length method
this method Returns the current length
of the deck
now let's understand the decline
algorithm in detail and how we'll use
the algorithm to solve the cardpool
problem
so it is early enforcement learning
algorithm that uses deep neural networks
to approximate the Q function in a q
learning algorithm so insert basically
it is that
but we need to understand the steps
involved to solve the cardpool
environment so let's look at that as
well so first we need to initialize the
Q network with random weights the second
is sample and action using an Epsilon 3D
policy basically we have covered this in
our
our Blackjack tutorial
which selects the action with the
highest Q value with probability 1 minus
Epsilon and a random action with a
probability Epsilon
execute the action and observe the next
state and reward
Store The Experience pupil in a briefly
buffer so we have implemented the class
already sample a mini batch for
experiences from the replay buffer we
have already created the method for that
compute the Q Target values for the mini
match using the Bellman equation so
basically this is how we calculate the
TQ value I'll explain to you when we
write the code compute the Q values for
the mini match using the current Q
Network so we'll have that value and we
just need to
compute the Q value for that
compute the loss between the Q values
and the queue Target values and update
the Q Network parameters using gradient
descent
and we'll keep doing these steps until
uh with this convergence or we reach a
fixed number of episodes so I I'll
explain detail what what we are going to
do to the end of the cardboard
the dqn algorithm uses a Target Network
to stabilize the training process the
target network is a copy of the Q
Network that is updated less frequently
than the Q Network
this helps to prevent the Q values from
oscillating during training so that's
what happened in our Blackjack uh when
we are solving blackjack
in cardpool environment the dqn
algorithm learns to balance the pole on
the cut by moving the cart left or right
the queue Network takes the state of the
environment as input and outputs the Q
values for each possible action the dqn
algorithm learns to maximize the Q
values by updating the Q Network
parameters using gradient descent with
enough training the dqn algorithm can
learn to balance the pole on the card
for extended periods of time
so basically this is all the steps
involved and how we are going to
solve the
card pole uh example the we are going to
balance out the card pool for a very
extended period of time
now let's go to our Q Network so let's
write some notes Here
so our model will be a convolutional
neural network it will take the
difference between the current and the
previous screen patches it will have two
outputs representing q s comma left and
q s comma right where s is the input to
the network
the in effect the network is trying to
predict the expected return of taking
each action given the current output so
basically this is our Q Network this is
the full implementation we'll have two
outputs
and the network is trying to predict the
expected return of taking each action
given the current input now let's
Implement our dqn class let's write the
class here let's write class d q and
and write NN dot module
yeah so then let's do left underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
self comma and underscore observations
comma n underscore actions
so I'll explain to you in detail let's
just complete the class first
and then we'll write the comments as
well so it will be very easy to
understand
be self dot underscore underscore init
self Dot
we'll have three layers let's do all the
three layers here two three is equal to
and then third linear
and underscore observations
128 so we'll have the size as 1128
let's do that we will the next one will
be 128 by 128
this is how it will be
now and the other one will be exactly
the opposite of this it'll be 128 by the
number of actions
comma and underscore actions
so we have implemented the
default unit Constructor let's go and
Define our method that is the forward
method
and refer to self
dot call this comma X
and X is equal to F Dot value
self dot layer 1X
and then we have so I've got layer 2X
and then we'll return the
cell dot layer 3x I've got
so we'll basically go to three layers
this is what the code defines
now let's understand what are we trying
to do here so
we have the Q Network which is a multi
perceptron so let's just keep writing it
down here
multi
per Mighty layer
or set front
any two independent and you can just use
perceptron
with three layers
so this is what we are trying to achieve
here
now we have what the input is it is a
tensor
so the what will be the input so it will
be a tensor of the size and underscore
observation is our size
interesting this is what we have passed
here
and actions good
is
our input
to the network
this is basically the state Network
input that is the state of the
environment
state of environment
to the network
so we have it's a fully connected layer
with 128 neurons followed by a value
activation function I'll also explain
like why we are using that
the second layer is also a fully
connected
layer with 128 neurons and a value
activation function
the final layer is a fully connected
layer with n axis where N Action
represents the number of possible axis
in the environment let's write it down
here
represents
I mean basically we can just write it
down
number of possible actions
[Applause]
environment
yeah now let's look at the forward
method what we have implemented here so
it will take the input as the tensor
that is the X tensor and we pass through
the first layer of the network using the
value activation function
pass
take input
and pass two three layers
of the network of the name of the NM
where this is the neural previous slide
block
yeah basically this is what we are
trying to do here
and what we are also trying to do is so
uh we'll pass it through the state to
the network and what we will get is the
output is the corresponding neuron in
the final layer so when you pass here we
will get an output we'll pass it to the
next layer and in the third layer we'll
finally return
so and what will happen here so during
training the Q network is updated using
the Bellman equation that we have
discussed already to minimize the mean
squared error between the target values
and the Q values
yeah so let's look at that
so now let's look at the training of our
dqn
so what we'll do is we'll have a Q
Network which is updated using the
Bellman equation to minimize the mean
squared error between the predicted Q
values and the target Q values the
target Q values are computed using the Q
network but with the weights Frozen and
not updated during the current iteration
of training this this helps to stabilize
the training process and prevent the
network from overfitting to the data
okay now let's look at all the other
parameters that will be have or I can
say parameters and utilities as well so
first we'll have select action it will
select an action according to the
Epsilon greedy policy we have again
covered this in the Blackjack tutorial
in the black when we are solving
Blackjack using queue learning we simply
put we will sometimes use our model
for choosing the action and sometimes
we'll just sample one uniformly so there
is no steps for that
but we'll uh or we'll see how we can do
that now the probability of choosing a
random action will start at EPS start
and will Decay exponentially towards EPS
end epsdk controls the rate of Decay so
basically this is the set of so we do
not have any particular Target value so
as we go along the values will keep
changing and we'll have to decide
whether we want to take a random action
or we want to think from the uh that
action that we have on the buffer
next we have plot durations it is a
helper for plotting the durations of
episodes along with an average over the
last 100 episodes The Measure used in
the official evaluations the plot will
be underneath the cell containing the
maintaining Loop and will update after
every episode so we'll plot this
training durations as well yes now go to
the code
so let's implement
our
all the parameters that we are going to
need so I'll have pack size
we have that size
equal to 128
gamma
is equal to zero point so I'll also
explain like let me just complete all
the parameter stores
yes start
start is equal to 0.9
we have EPs and
equal to 0.05 so basically this is when
we will end
this is our Epsilon end
May VPS Decay rate
which is going to be 1000 and we have
the top which is going to be 0.005
and our learning rate is going to be
1 E raised to minus 4.
yeah this is our this is what is going
to be here
now let's write the comments as well
what is going to be the batch size
number of
transitions
sampled
from the as you play buffer
I'm going to be comma it is gamma let's
just copy down
Obama is the discount
Factor as mentioned
in my area this is going to be the
discount Factor here
so what is going to be the EPS start
let's go there
is the final value of episode
is the starting value of the Epsilon
basically we can just write it next to
it as well so we don't have to waste the
time we're just starting now it is
and the starting value
of Epsilon
let's look at the EPs and it is the
ending value of
final value of Epsilon
let's look at the epsdk in EPS apsdk
controls so we need to let me just
basically
controls the rate of
exponential decay
then share decay of Epsilon
higher means the slower rate so first
we'll start very very slow rate and then
we'll keep
improving on our learning rates
so this is going to be
higher means lower end
slower decay
yeah
let's look at
our this as well it is a it is the
update rate of the target Network
so what is Tau Tau is the
and what is going to be the LR it is
going to be the learning rate
so this is going to be of the Adam
Optimizer so let's look at now what is
now this is the perfect time to
understand about the Adam W optimizer I
mean item Optimizer and Adam Optimizer
as well
so basically now let's look at the Adam
Optimizer so basically we've defined it
here
we'll be needing all these parameters
and we'll be needing it for the Adam
Optimizer so this is the learning rate
for the item optimizer
So Adam adaptive moment estimation is a
popular optimization algorithm that is
commonly used in deep learning it is an
extension of stochastic gradient descent
if you do not know about that it's okay
you can still watch the rest of the
video which is the most basic
optimization algorithm used to train
neural networks the main idea behind
Adam is to combine the advantages of two
other optimization techniques add a grad
and RMS prop so if you do not know about
that as well it's okay in the dqn
algorithm we use Adam Optimizer to
update the weights of our neural network
based on the gradients of the loss
function with respect to the parameters
so we have defined our loss function as
1 minus Epsilon
specifically we use the Adam W Optimizer
which is a variant of the atom so we
have defined it here
which is a variant of the atom that also
incorporates weight decay regularization
weight Decay helps prevent overfitting
by adding a penalty to the loss function
that is proportional to the magnitude of
the weights
by adding this penalty in the optimizer
encourages the network to learn simpler
and more generalizable representations
the learning rate is a hyper parameter
that controls the step size taken during
optimization
it is an important parameter to tune as
the high learning rate can cause the
optimizer to overshoot the optimal
weights and lead to Divergence while a
low learning rate can result in slow
convergence and getting stuck in a local
Minima in dqn algorithm we set the
learning rate to 1
e raised to minus 1.
so basically this is what this is why we
are going to use
the item Optimizer so we do not get
stuck in a local Minima yeah so we need
to control the learning rate and pull
the content in the running rate we need
the Addam W optimizer in summary the
Adam W Optimizer it is is a wiley is a
widely used optimization algorithm in
deep learning
and it is used in DQ and algorithm to
update the weights of the neural network
based on the gradients of the loss
function with respect to the parameters
while also incorporating weight decay
regularization
so this is the very critical role played
by Adam W optimizer
now let's so now we have learned about
Adam Optimizer now let's learn about now
let's uh write the code for the other
other utilities that are pending
so the first
variable that we have is the n actions
which is going to be EnV dot
action.action space so basically this is
going to be the action space of the
cardpool environment
so that will be
let's keep it up let's just keep
writing the number uh the comments as
well get number of
actions from
Zoom action space
also now let's do that get
the number of
State observations which is
going to be State comma
info so basically this is going to be
the Tuple that we talked about it will
convert all the information related
to the current state the current
state that we are in
observations
is going to be length of State
now let's create our policy net
which is going to be a class it is going
to be an instance of the DQ and class
we have this will be n underscore
observations
comma and underscore actions
dot two device
so basically devices that what we have
set up
through Target net as well
Target net is equal to same thing
now let's load the state
Target Dot
score net dot load underscore state
underscore dick
to policy
underscore net dot state
I think it is
yeah now let's complete the optimizer as
well so I'll just come back and explain
to you everything is just complete the
optimizer also now
to optim basically where this is going
to be the torch method opt-in
but to be Adam w we discussed about atom
W I have to explain to you the atom W
Optimizer and the atom Optimizer as well
want to be policy
underscore net dot parameters
okay parameters learning it we have
already defined
small error is equal to capital r root
layer is defined here
one e raised to minus four
comma amps guard
Ms grad so like I'm listening to you
what this means as well
let's complete the code memory
so we'll be taking the last 10 000
episodes for our memory
do we play
memory
10 000 will pass Ten Thousand Years
so our buffer size is going to be ten
thousand let's define the steps done as
well
obviously this is where we currently are
okay
let's let's go ahead and just complete
all the methods let's do the select
action as well basically this is going
to be the method that will help us
select any action so if I have a state
it will just tell us
which methods are done
so let's do that
steps underscore done
sample is equal to random
dot sample
I think it is wrong and it is random or
random
and we'll see PPS underscore
threshold is equal to eps
underscore end
Plus
thank you
MPS underscore start we have defined all
these parameters before also
eps
underscore end
into so we have to divide it by
oh sorry yeah we need to go to the next
line so it will do slash
slash math Dot
math Dot
component of -1
import Star of steps
done
byps detail
Epsilon Decay yeah you see this is going
to be the equation
and then let's do steps done
once we are done with this
we need to do steps done plus equal to
one
will argument with those sample
with an EPS underscore
threshold
window with torch dot no grad so
basically
we'll be doing that you've had
we'll do T Dot
Max
1 will turn the largest column of each
row
this column value
of
each row
you can
see this is row
we have the second column
second column on Max result
index of where Max element was
was found
so we pick action with largest yeah so
we need to like yeah we need to optimize
for the larger reward right
basically this is what we are going to
do
expected reward
let's do return
policy
scorenet
state DOT Max
Dot View
one comma one
now we need to do the else of this as
well
it is good
let's see this is the else
torch dot tensor
pnv.actions. so we'll just return the
action space
action underscore space dot samples so
basically this is what we are going to
do is
we'll see if we want to take a sample
one or we need to keep continuing the
path that we are on
so let's do that
okay
now also take the device is equal to
device
and comma D type
is equal to torch dot now
okay
so I'll explain to you all these
utilities let's just complete all the
methods while we are at it
so it is equal to episode underscore
durations
foreign
okay
so what we'll do is
we just go over all the methods that we
completed
so
the N actions is the number of actions
in the environments in the environment's
action space so will be the gym
environments State comma info are
obtained by resetting the environment
and N observations
is the number of features in the state
let's just write it down as well
in the state
let's do the target net is initiated
with the same weight as policy net okay
Target net
initialized
with the same weight
as
policy net
then we have the optimizer
which is
in the atom Optimizer Adam W optimizer
optimizer
is Adam W optimizer
and MW
and W optimizer
by torch with the learning rate and
other hyper parameters specified earlier
so we use it to optimize the weights
choose to optimize
the weights we've already passed all the
parameters that we needed
let's go to the memory so
the memory is an instance of the replay
memory and it has a capacity of 10 000.
okay so let's just write why we will
store
engines experiences
which will be
induced for training
for training
let's do steps done
it is a it is it is used to keep track
of
the steps number of texts
keep track
of number of texts taken by the agent
this is what we are going to start with
we're going to start with zero
now let's understand the step action
method as well so it takes the current
state as input let's just write it down
and put this
current state
and returns an action
so it could be either that the action is
it could be selected by choosing the
action with the highest Q value so this
is going to be the highest Q value
or it could be that we have taken a
random so how we are going to decide so
we are going to decide by this
expression
so we discussed earlier that we are
going to be calculating the threshold
value and if the sample is less than the
threshold value and we have no grad then
we go to the maximum
or Q isq value that we have that we find
or we take the random one random
approach so basically this is going to
be the
envy.xn.sample I will take the sample
and the device will be either a CPU or
GPU in our case it is the GPU that we
have defined earlier
and then last we have episode durations
it is used to keep track of
of the duration
duration of each episode
okay
so now let's also complete the plot
durations method which will plot all the
duration of each
and that is taken by the agent
we have show result is equal to false we
have
to start with
the PLT dot trigger
basically we are going to plot so we are
going to be using
Pi plot here
durations underscore T is equal to torch
dot tensor
we have the episode underscore durations
comma D type is equal to tors dot float
if so underscore result
PLT dot title result we're going to be
keeping the title
result else
do that we have false so basically the
first time it will be just the title
then we'll plot
the graphs as well let's do that now to
training training graphs
training
PLT dot X next level
is going to be episode
and then we have pldt dot y label
which is
duration
then we have
PLT Dot Plot
durations obviously we think this
munition and the refrigerations
Dot numpy
we'll convert it to the numpy array
and then we'll take 100 episode averages
so let's just write it down
first let's do that if length
greater than 100 greater than equal to
100.
um
then means
durations underscore D dot unfold
zero
to slice it then we'll take the mean
then we'll take the
other view as well
means is equal to
equal to
rch.cat
it's going to be tors.cat Taurus dot
zeros
99 and then we have the means
then we have PLT Dot Plot
new DOT
numpy
let's add a pause
so then we have
PLT Dot
was zero point zero zero
one
pause so that
plots are updated
and then if we have a display so
basically I'll just write it down so
that it works on all the environments if
you just run it in your local vs code
also it should work right
so it will be show
underscore result
display dot display
plt.gcf
and display
Dot
clear output
weight is equal to true
else
display.displayer
PLT dot GCF so I'll explain to you what
all this
Lots mean so yeah if we are done
so we have completed the method let's
now go and write some comments so
basically it will be very clear
for all of you
so this method is
used
to visualize
visualize the training progress of the
dqn
basically this is the method here now
first we'll create a tensor
from episode durations so basically this
is the it will keep track of the lengths
of each duration
and then we'll plot it using mac.lib and
if we have the show result as true then
we'll label it as result or as it will
be training
and uh the x axis is labeled as episodes
the Y is labeled as duration
and we have a function that is called we
have a variable that is called
durations underscore T is a blue line
and overlays
with a deadline that shows the 100
episode moving average of the durations
so let's just write it down
shows the
with a piece sword
moving average
of the durations
yeah
so finally we'll wait for just a second
so that the plots are updated
and it will come in real time
and if you have a job notebook then we
use can use this method as we'll just
use a normal method
so so now let's start our training Loop
so let's create our optimize model here
optimize
score model
select this from spaces
if
length
less than match
underscore size
then return
so we do not need to optimize at the
start
then we have the transitions
when we take a memory dot sample so
basically this is the sampling
we will do the sampling
okay then we have the batch
is equal to
transition
dot zip
so this disability this looks a little
bit complicated but I'll explain to you
like why we do this so basically we
transpose the batch
and it will convert the batch array of
transitions to transition of Bachelor is
so let's write it down
converts batch array
match array of transitions
to transition
of batteries
now let's compute the mask of non-final
states
absolutely being non underscore final
underscore mask is equal to torch dot
answer
then we have that Tuple
into the map let's write a Lambda
function here
Lambda s this is not none
comma
batch dot next
state
command device
is equal to device
okay
this will be better
this is done
so let's write down what this method
will do what we are planning to do here
we are going to compute
a mask of
non-finance States
and
concatenate the batch elements
thank you
okay and the final state will be where
the simulation ends basically there will
be that
it's done
let's do the I think we have to forgot
the parameter here it will be D type
it's equal to
rres dot Boolean
yep I'm going to pass this
yeah now let's
do the non final next States
is equal to dot dot cat
as far as
in batch
batch dot next state
yes
if f is not not
then we have the
date underscore batch
is equal to torch dot cat
badge dot state
then we have the action batch let's just
write it down
reaction batch
reward batch
yeah because this is batch dot action
this is badge.reward
so now let's compute the Q value now
state
the score action
score values
is equal to policy net basically this is
uh the policy that we are planning to
use right
policy net
let's go batch
dot gather
one comma action batch
foreign
compute the next state values also
next underscore state
so which will be the final state if it
is ending then it will be
uh zero
in case the finance the it gives this
state was the final state it will be
torch dot zero
match
the score size
comma device is equal to device
now with no
no torch torch.nograd
we do
next underscore State underscore values
is of non underscore final mask
is equal to Target net so it looks a
little bit complicated but trust me when
I explained to you after writing the
code it will be pretty clear
understood States
this is the looks code looks intimating
but what we're trying to do is pretty
simple
you've got maths
one
of zero
now let's also compute the expected Q
value
yeah to expected underscore State
underscore action value
I think uh yeah I forgot that yeah we
need to do this first here we can do
this first generation
underscore values
is equal to next state values
values to gamma
Plus reward
reward batch
let's calculate the number loss as well
I'll explain to you what police means
in the losses writerion
to
is equal to NN Dot
smooth
L one loss
yeah so this is the name loss is equal
to
State underscore action
score values
comma expected
underscore state
score action
will be expected
for State underscore action
score values Dot and
squeeze one
now let's optimize
preview Optimizer Dot
basically yeah at the end you need to do
optimizer
dot 0
underscore grad
University loss dot backward
basically we will do that as well let's
do in place
so it must be
looking like
it's pretty tough but trust me I'll
explain to you pretty it's a little bit
clearer then
Dodge Dot
utils
not clip grad value
and add value
underscore
policy
dot net dot parameters
commanded
yeah and then first we'll clip the
values now let's do optimizer Dot
okay
now let's look at this so first we check
if this is a mini batch so we have the
optimize method right so this is uh BP
learning uh implementation that is
nothing what we already know so let's
check what we do so first we replay
memory
so first we check if the replay memory
contains enough samples to fill up a
mini batch
so let's write it down
if check if
we have enough samples for uh
mini match if you do not then return
nothing then do nothing okay and then
let's go to transition
so first thing we want to do is we take
Minimax
extract
new abstract extract
a mini match
up transitions
create formation
comma reward
comma Next Step
from the replay memory
play
memory
now
then also what we do is we calculated
calculate the expected Q value
and it is the sum of the immediate
reward
so basically we have it here
oh yeah
so we have the gamma as well
I cannot see gamma Yeah so basically
it's just search program
yeah so this is where we do the expected
State calculation
so what we do is
calculate the
expected Q value
Q value for each transition
using the target Network
basically we have created our neural
network here
now if you do not know how to create a
basic neural network no issues
okay
Yeah so basically it is the sum
of the immediate reward
and the discounted Q value of the next
state
okay so now under this contractor is
controlled by the gamma
okay now let's see the function
now what we'll do is we'll uh calculate
the Q value predicted by the policy
Network for each transition
and we'll also select the queue
corresponding to the action taken by the
agent so basically that's what we are
doing here we are also selecting
now we need to calculate the hover loss
as well
the upper loss is a smooth approximation
of the mean squared error loss and is
less sensitive to outliers
so we need to be less sensitive smooth
what is the herbal loss it is a smooth
approximation
if you do not understandable loss no
issues we can just look it up
but it's a pretty
good metric for calculating the error
loss
less sensitive
yeah
basically this is double loss as well
and now finally
we back propagate now to the policy
Network and update the parameters using
the Adam W optimizer
and we also have clipped it to a maximum
of 100
to prevent the exploding gradient
problem
so
maximum
value is equal to 100 to prevent
exploding
gradient problem
so now let's go on to the main Loop now
main training Loop so we have completed
the training part of it now we need to
create
we're going to start implementing the
algorithm let's do that now so what
we'll do is if tors dot Coda basically
I'm just making the code in such a way
that if you do not have a GPU you can
use this code
you don't have to make any changes
so then you need to make number
underscore episodes
you can just keep it 50.
and oh sorry if it is available then I
will keep it 600 else I'll give it 50.
now
now let's Loop over the episodes
for I underscore episode
in range of number of episodes
to state so I don't I think you all know
what uh this does is we reset the
environment and get the current state
and all the information that we need
yeah
let's just write it down again
initialize the environment
and get its state
and also state is equal to torch the
tensor
State comma D type is equal to
torch.flow32
comma device is equal to device
and let's do unsqueeze
zero
I think you all know what we're doing
here I've already explained it once
let's look let's create another loop now
we have t in count number of count here
little reaction is equal to select
action so we need to select an action
here
select underscore action false so first
for the first time we do not want
anything
we have passed the state and we want
observation
comma reward
comma terminated
command and create it
and any other parameter that we get
is equal to EnV dot step
let's do it here
thank you
equal to
Excel dot item so we need to take the
action dot item here
and then
get actually make a step forward so
we'll get the new observation we want
Terminator and
your truncated value
yeah now let's give define the reward as
well we have taken a step forward now
let's
open the reward
toward the tensor
reward
comma device
equal to device
and we have done is equal to
terminated or truncated
and we have if
yeah so we can either have that we have
completed the number of steps or that we
have
uh of the card if the card pool has
fallen of 2.4
meters away from the center
which basically that could be that
next underscore state
is equal to none
else we need to define the next state
we'll do that
else
for next state will be
quite tensor
tensor observation
observation comma B type is equal to
torch
dot float 32 comma device
equal to device
Dot and quiz
zero
and you can take it there yeah
now let's add this next step in memory
so
we can do that using memory.push we have
created that in our class
action
I think we already have all this here
okay actually
next state yeah we have the next video
and we have the reward also
now store let's just keep writing
comments as well store
the transition
and then move to next set let's move to
the next hit as well
[Applause]
matched it
Yeah so basically we move to the next
step let's optimize the model now
we have already
created the medal for that the method
for that now let's do the soft update of
the target Network weights so we already
have that
new Target underscore net underscore
state
underscore dict Let's see we need to do
it
for both the Target and the policy Nets
equal to Target
underscore net dot State underscore dict
so like if you if you're finding it
pretty difficult it's okay I they happen
to be the first time as well but once
I've completed the code I'll just go
over everything once again so everything
becomes very clear
for key in policy net I think we have to
take this one
this is the policy net let's do training
net
and then we need to do key
is equal to policy net
underscore net underscore State
underscore date
of key
so we need to multiply it by the Tau
divide Tau
plus Target net state
so the old value also
into one minus Tau basically this is
what we are planning to do now
1 minus Tau
yeah this is what we're doing now let's
see if we are done we are going to do a
soft update and then if we are done
so I think I have explained to you what
is the difference between episode
and an iteration
so basically an episode is the one
sequence between a start and an end so
basically in the cardboard instance the
start will be when we started at the
initial set and then if we fall off 2.4
meters away from the center or that we
have completed the game basically we
have achieved the maximum
uh state that we could maximum number of
times we could have
we could have played this game
so this is one this is going to be one
one time that we are going to play the
game basically and we are for if you
have a GPU we're going to do this 600
times so basically we have to play this
game 600 times
there's no durations
and let's do break now
now let's
complete it
so finally yeah we have completed
then we are going to plot all the
durations
basically what I encourage is you can
just keep changing the number of
durations and check the results
basically that is something I want you
to do and I'm not going to do that I'm
just going to stick to the 600 episodes
because I have a GPU
I of and PLT not show
we're done with the cardpool environment
as well let's quickly summarize
everything that we have learned so
what the agent has to decide it has to
decide between two actions moving the
card left or right so basically this is
a video Loop here so as you can see
either the
cardpool will move left or right and we
need to balance it out
so now uh
I've explained all this in detail
let's look at all the
methods that we have imported so we have
imported the torch.nn which is used for
our neural network we have imported the
tors.opter method which is for
optimization
we have imported autogrand which is for
automatic differentiation and also I
have explained in detail what each of
this is used to extend each of this in
detail as well
now we have started with the import of
the modules that we need
also we have started so basically we
have installed it and here we have
imported all the methods that we need
here we have set up the environment
and also I've also made it such that you
can run it in the Google collab or
notebook as well or also in just uh any
python script as well so it will adjust
accordingly
then we have detected if Cuda is
available which is a GPU
now I have also explained to you what is
the concept of Replay memory basically
it is a technique used in reinforcement
learning to store and manage the
experiences of an agent during training
so basically we'll make use of this we
have uh
saved all of the
steps that the agent takes and use that
to make any future decisions
so we are going to make two classes one
transition class and one replay memory
class so basically we have the
transition here and then we have the
replay memory class here
and we are going to use the dqn
algorithm it is a deep Q Network which
is a reinforcement learning algorithm
that uses deep learning deep neural
networks to approximate the queue
function I have explained to you the
queue function and we have also learned
about the Q learning algorithm when we
were solving blackjack
so we have basically I have written all
the steps that we would be using to
solve the cardpool environment using the
DQ and algorithm
then we have implemented the class for
that as well then we come to the
training section
during training the Q network is updated
using the Bellman equation I have
explained the Bellman equation as well
to minimize the mean squared error
between the predicted Q values and the
target Q values the target Q values are
completed using the Q network but with
the weights Frozen and not updated
during the current iteration of training
now we have
some important Concepts here so
basically this is a select action
as well
so I have explained to you all these
hyper parameters as well let's go to a
very important concept that is the Adam
optimizer So Adam adaptive moment
estimation is a popular optimization
algorithm that is commonly used in deep
learning it is an extension of
stochastic gradient descent which is the
most basic optimization algorithm used
to train neural networks the main idea
behind Adam is to combine the advantages
of two other optimization techniques
undergrad and RMS profit here I've
explained detail how we'll be using it
in our DQ and algorithm
next
we get the number of actions from the
gym action space we set up we reset the
environment and get the initial state we
set up the number of
features that we have we have the item
Optimizer we have initialized our
training neural network as well we have
the replay memory which is a 10 000
buffer
which is content 10 000 last 10 000
episodes
then basically this is the training Loop
I've explained in detail as well
then we have the optimize model
this method will optimize the model so
basically what we need to do is we need
to just
take a mini batch so and also we will be
using sampling as well
so we have gone through that
now we have uh started with the training
so we'll detect if Coda is available
that is the GPU is available then we'll
do 600 episodes or else we'll do only
500 episodes
so
yeah this is the training Loop and then
we have plotted the end result this
chart I have also explained in detail
how we use this chart to understand the
performance of our algorithm
so now we have completed our solving of
blackjack using queue learning so
basically
now let's move on to the advanced topics
that we are going that you could cover
and that you will explore after learning
this beginners tutorial so you can
explore the enforcement learning
deep reinforcement learning is a
combination of deep learning and
reinforcement learning that uses neural
networks to approximate the Q values in
queue learning deep RL algorithms such
as deep Q Network and actor critic have
been successful in solving complex tasks
such as Atari games Robotics and
autonomous battery
so basically this is what you can
explore you can dive into a autonomous
driving now
policy gradients policy gradient
algorithms directly optimize the policy
function by adjusting the parameters of
the policy through gradient ascent this
allows the agent to learn a policy that
maximize the the Mac that maximizes the
expected reward without Computing the Q
values
the advantage of policy gradient
algorithm is that they can handle
continuous action spaces unlike queue
learning so this is a bit interesting
you can also explore this
now let's move on to multi-agent
reinforcement learning yeah so this is
pretty uh interesting now you can uh
have two three cars in an environment
and you can just simulate that and you
can use petting zoo for that so petting
zoo is a brother of
and it allows it gives us an environment
for multi-agent reinforcement learning
multi-agent reinforcement learning
extends reinforcement learning to the
scenario where multiple agents interact
with each other in a shared environment
in multi-reinforcement learning each
multi-agent reinforcement learning each
agent learns this policy based on the
joint reward received by all agents the
open air gymnasium toolkit provides
environments for Mal such as the classic
prisoners dilemma game and Cooperative
navigation tasks
so this sounds pretty interesting
imitation learning also known as
learning from demonstration is a
technique that trains an agent to mimic
the behavior of an expert this approach
has been used in various applications
such as autonomous driving Robotics and
game learning in gameplay gymnasium
toolkit includes environments from
immigration learning such as music
Locomotion task
so this also sounds pretty interesting
now let's look at the last topic that
you could cover in the advanced topics
so this is transfer learning transfer
learning is the technique of
transferring knowledge learned in one
task to another related task in
reinforcement learning transfer learning
can help speed up the learning process
and improve the performance of the agent
the open AI gymnasium toolkit provides
environments for transfer learning such
as the classic inverted pendulum tasks
and card pole swing of dust
so now we talked about multi-agent
reinforcement learning so let's check
out putting Zoo documentation that I
mentioned so what we can do is here
you can check out all the different
types of environment that are available
so for diary games we have all the
we have Mario Bros for multi-agent so we
have Luigi and Mario here
all the the action space is defined so I
have explained all the concepts here so
it wouldn't be very difficult for you to
start implementing these
we have Space Invaders so basically
these are different types of games
available let's check out
classic games so we have chess so we can
play chess as well
so I highly encourage you to go
first let's uh first when you understand
the basics then I highly encourage you
to go out and check out the petting zoo
documentation and study creating your
own environments and your own agents and
solve some real world problems